[Musique]
tout ce qu'elle a ils touchent pas ça
c'est à partie à y jouer à 8,10 coach
que vous avez déjà qu'à une partie du
frigo un peu comme les colocs ce
planning mais la salle de bains a été
conçu en fonction de mes horaires si
j'ai envie de pisser leur planning par
exemple on fait comment on demande
gentiment l'autorisation définit ce que
tu peux ouvrir la porte s'il te plaît
j'aime aller faire pipi en fait très
longtemps j'ai rendez-vous hyper
important je suis à la bourre si tu
pouvais mourir s'il te plait je les
demande poliment ouvre au mazel porte je
m'en fou j'étais là avant tu louvre qui
longe toujours que sinon quoi et vas-y
voilà tous des pères depuis ce temps je
dois faire je mens coupe tu vois
toujours qu'on arrive à déterrer 3ware
je fais pas ça vous laisse entre adultes